وفي سياق رده على القرار الاوروبي قال
المتحدث باسم الكريملاند متر بيسكوف ان
موسكو لن تعترف باي سقف لاسعار الطاقه
واكد ان روسيا تجهز اجراءات للرد على وضع
الاتحاد الاوروبي سقفا لسعر النفط الروسي
واصفا الخطوه بالمزعزعه الاستقرار سوق
طاقه العالميه واشدد بسكوف على ان
العقوبات على روسيا تلحق ضررا واضحا
بالدول الاوروبيه لا يمكن انكاره كما
انتقد ما قال انه غياب لاي تحول في سياسه
الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان تسويه دبلوماسيه في
اوكرانيا
ينضم الينا من موسكم مراسل الجزيره امينه
دورغامي ومن برلين مراسل الجزيره عيسى
طبيبي عيسى ما هي اصداء تجديد الصين على
ان تعاونها في مجال النفط مع روسيا مستمر
ولي يتاثر بصقف الاسعار
في مؤتمر صحفي في الهند مع ناظر الهندي
بان برلين تنظر الى الصين كتحدا ومنافس
المنهجي وتنظر اليها بانها ايضا شريك في
القضايا العالميه وبالتالي هذا الامر
اسقاطاته واضحه على ملف الالي المحدده من
طرف الغرب لتحديد سعر همم نفطر الروسي همم
نعلم جيدا مفيدا بان الدول الغربيه همم
تهيمن على 90% من قطاع التامين والشحن
العالمي وبالتالي هي قادره على فرض هذا
السعر هذا السقف على الدول التي تشتري
النفط الروسي الصين لن تكون في من امن هذه
المنهجيه باعتبارنا الهيمنه الغربيه قد
تصل ايضا الى الصين كل شركاء روسيا سيصلهم
هذا الثقه بمعنى اخر بان هذه الدول عليها
ان تشتري النفط الروسي ب 90 ابي عفوا ب 60
او بالدولار او اقل من ذلك والا فانها سوف
لن تمنح عمليه التامين طبعا والتي تهيمن
عليها هذه الدول الامر الاخر الذي يتجر
الاشاره اليه بان هذه النقطه رغم ان
الغربيين متحمسون لها الا ان اليوم الاصى
في برلين تحديدا تتحدث لربما ستكون قفزه
نحو المجهول لماذا لان دخول اوبك بلس على
الخط سيؤدي الى زعزعه زعزعه تاريخيه في
الاسواق ونتحدث هنا عن احتماليه الانكماج
وغيرها من المعطيات الاخرى التي ترى برلين
باننا ينبغي ان نضع ان نقدر مواضع قبل
الخط وفي هكذا قرار نعم ابقى معنا عيسى
انتقل اليك امين امين ما هي الخيارات
المحتمله التي يمكن ان تلجا اليها روسيا
للرد على هذه القرارات
[تصفيق]
من خلال تصريح نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
الكسندر نوفاك امس بشان هذه الخطوه قال
بان روسيا لن تقبل اولا وقبل كل شيء بهذه
بهذا السعر الذي وضعته الدول الغربيه وان
اضطرت الى تخفيض حجم انتاجها اليومي وطبعا
والخبراء يعلمون جيدا ماذا يعني ذلك
باعتبار ان روسيا همم تنتج اكثر من 10
ملايين
و800,000 برميل من النفط يوميا وهناك
تقديرات على مستوى الخبراء في مجال الطاقه
هنا في روسيا على ان يؤدي هذا الانخفاض
الى فقدان اكثر من مليونيه همم برميل من
ان الروسي يوميا من الاسواق وذلك يعني انا
الاسعار سترتفع الى اكثر من 100 دولار
قال لي البرميل في سوق الطاقه العالميه
لكن روسيا لها خيارات طبعا تتحدث عنها منذ
فتره طويله وهي التي كانت دائما تعلم بان
الغرب سيلجا الى هذه الخطوه في نهايه
المطاف اول هذه
الحلول لنقل هو تحويل صادراتها الى الدول
التي بدات بالفعل تشتري نسبه اكبر من ان
نفطر روسيه من الحديث طبعا عن الصين
والهند هناك تقديرات بان الصادرات الى
الصين على سبيل المثال ارتفعت باكثر من
30% وهناك ايضا خيار اخر وهو تركيا التي
ايضا تنوي شراء النفط وتنوي همم تلعب على
ربما في المستقبل المنظور دورا محوريه
لتصدير همم نفطر الروسي الى العالم وان
تكون طريقا امنا بالنسبه لروسيا من اجل
تصديرها
والالتفاف على هذه العقوبات ان روسيا في
الحقيقه همم تحاول ان تبدا تحرك على مستوى
اوبك بلس من اجل ربما توحيد الجهود من اجل
تفادي اي همم عوائق او عواقب لنقل على همم
النفط وايضا على اسعار الطاقه الدوليه
امين درغامي وراسل الجزيره من موسكو شكرا
لك واشكر موصول ايضا عيسى الطيبي مراسل
للجزيره من برلين